inflation is stunningly successful but
it cannot account for its own origin in
order to account for its origin It must
invoke the Multiverse and so does that
trouble you or is that just really a
signpost that we need better ideas I
think we certainly need better ideas I
think that it is remarkable that there
are a set of predictions from inflation
that we have sort of checked off most of
them already we're now together right
we're looking for one of the key
predictions of the early universe of the
inflation model Universe which is that
it should imprint space-time ripples
gravitational waves permeating the early
universe and so we should certainly look
for them but I think even if we find
them I wouldn't be ready to say oh
inflation happened this is what it is
problem solved